le revenu universel en finlande est une
excellente idée qui est venue du
gouvernement de droite
mahler ce prénom du gouvernement de
droite de la finlande pour s'assurer
qu'il ya un linéaire de la première
université pour tous les finlandais
le problème était bien sûr que yann
impose un appauvrissement relative de la
population qui est arrivé et on veut
être sûrs qu'il épouse pour la faune que
la flore en sont compétitives à long
terme de s'assurer que tout le monde et
elle aura le revenu un revenu qui assure
une bonne retraite de bons services d
assurance pour l'avenir parce que le
plus grand bien finlandais qui dans
lequel on a toujours investi depuis 60
ans qui a fait en sorte que ce petit
pays de mieux que de petits pays
miraculeux dans plusieurs domaines de la
haute technologie et dans d'autres
domaines comme l'éducation
c'était un investissement dans les
finlandais et c'est ce que le même
engouement de droite finlandais a voulu
faire pour l'avenir de la faire